I was going to say I wore this to Pixar
because I figured I'm putting it into
the world that I'd like Pixar to make a
Star Blazers movie and by wearing it to
Pixar I'm like you know putting it into
the no you're marrying they're all
original man you know something but but
does it have to be all original this
could it be some IP that not many people
know let me spin you know so let me
start with let's jump into the movie so
let me start with congratulations and I
I really mean that sincerely this movie
uh meant a lot to me it's a very
personal story because I went through
something similar but enough about me
when you guys were offered the roles
finally or however you got them how much
did you think you were being punked
because you know lead roles and Pixar I
feel pretty fun
like for sure
first could actually happen I mean the
process to even audition
that was really shocking I think it was
so surreal that I like wasn't as nervous
because I was like this can't be true
like this isn't actually happening but
then after the six hour audition in
person after talking with Peter on zoom
and doing all the different rounds they
tell me at the end of my audition and
that was like I felt punked because they
said like okay like great job today on
your audition and by the way we'd love
to offer you the role of Ember Lumen and
I was like
no no yes yes that's only happened to me
I think one other time is for a front
runner
but
funny story
Jason Reitman was the director love love
him
we have a great set like quick session
and he's like you got the part
and I'm like what and I leave and I call
my agent like I think he just offered me
the part in in the room
and then and then my agent calls me back
he's like no he didn't and I was like
why do you say why do you say that why
do you say that so then I go back I do
the call back and with like all right
Greiner and he says congratulations you
got the part and I'm looking at him like
yeah we'll see about that
it ended up getting the part it was so
funny no you didn't I was like no you
know you'd like what
why do you tell me that you got me
imagine after they were like just
kidding
honestly like I I don't I don't know if
I could put myself through what a lot
What actors go through in terms of
putting themselves out there all the
time trying you know what I mean you're
like
uh I definitely want to one of the
things about uh I'm not sure if you knew
going in what the recording process was
really going to be like and because it
changes so much throughout the process
and you're anyway so what surprised you
both about the recording process and and
part two is at what point did you're
like I just can't cry anymore oh that
was never a problem nothing but serious
like this movie's so beautiful and it's
everything that I've ever wanted to do I
I got an endless wall for that
um I was surprised how exhausting it was
I was very surprised how exhausting the
recording sessions are
which I was sweating too I mean that's
not what you just said but I was like
like I need a second and then on top of
that as well I think I just surprised
myself because you know you go and you
you you kind of get the sides a night
before because they're always constantly
changing and you know I go in the booth
and I'm like okay what are we gonna cook
up today like how am I going to drown or
how am I going to be running on a train
and how am I going to go from like being
super cheery with my dad to you know
crying that Wade's getting
I don't want to give spoilers wait
something happens to Wade and so
mix and match I just really surprised
myself but it wasn't even it wasn't
really me like it was Peter like to have
a leader and director who is so gentle
and and fearless with you and
understands kind of the emotions you
need to get to where you need to go and
be patient with that like there's no
greater gift than having a creative that
understands the tools that you kind of
need you know so that was really cool
too at what you have to a lot of people
don't know what efforts are but you
obviously had to do a lot of efforts you
know
we did a lot of efforts I almost passed
out doing the like how to breathe
but I was going to say
I'm assuming they saved all those to
like the end of the day or
yes they saved my I asked them to save
my yelling and explosions at the end of
the day but also the breathing stuff as
well I almost passed out too actually
what I want to talk about I almost
passed out doing like it was like oh I'm
playing games this is not a game it's
not a game it's not a game you thought
yeah I thought wrong yeah sorry no I was
gonna say I I don't think a lot of
people realize voice over voice
recording is really acting it's really a
lot of work and I think when from the
outside
um maybe it looks easy but it's it's not
it's not you'd think that you just get
to go in and be like okay oh like I hit
this but I think like because you can't
see what the actor is doing you have to
put even more extra effort into I think
making a grander version of grabbing a
bag or like sniffling or laughing and
different things like that
um but it was actually really really
cool because there were a couple times
when I'd be like okay was that realistic
enough and like we would have to listen
to it back and be like actually we're
kind of going for this do you mind like
trying to breathe in a way where like
the walls are closing in on you versus
like this way and I'm like okay okay
okay I think I could try that so it's
just like kind of like problem problem
shooting and just trying different
things too yeah it's kind of just I mean
fundamentally for me it was just like uh
vortexing or exploding and then finding
the spaces in between like you'd Vortex
for The Quiet Moments and you're just
having this intimate one-on-one and it's
like very and then there's like you know
a whole weight in Amber both get where
it's just like very effusive and
acceleratory or you scary or you know
very emotional
um and just like you but you have to put
all of yourself into each level of that
no matter how the what the size is sure
so that's where it's like oh this is it
takes quite quite a bit of focus and um
energy it's fun though yeah I already
have to wrap I'm just going to say one
last thing I really enjoyed that there's
no villain in this yeah it's really
about family and characters and it's not
some person trying to take over the city
yeah you know what I mean yeah I do know
what you mean that's exactly what I love
about it well one of the things I love
about it as well on that note I'm just
gonna say congrats and uh you know uh
congrats on being part of a big Pixar
movie it's [__] awesome thanks you
know what I mean